you want a psychedelic tree you know 30
years the psychedelic voice and I can
just steal it for you this is not a
psychedelic truth victim truth here it
is and you can learn this some drugs you
can learn it from life you can learn
this from death you can learn it any way
you like but by god you will learn give
nothing left
not last not your enemy not your brand
not your youth not your dream not your
tears not your coat
not even yourself nothing lasts and it
has been fed awesome but felt rarely you
know Heraclitus said come to Korea all
blue and and the lie of Western
psychology is that something is stable
God's nature the equinoctial point pumps
and lands and and because of this lie
we are perpetually in a state of anxiety
because the truth of our experience do
nothing less and yet the truth that our
culture tells us is you know save your
immortal soul make the contribution
preserve protect confirmed stabilized
retained
we did with Portland and and so the
central truth of being is the felt
president of immediate reality that all
you will ever have and so the quality of
the presence of the museum experience is
what you want to impact and determine
and everything else you do get a whole
tree memory projection but the felt
presence of immediate experience is that
is not satisfying students you have to
change your life you have to do stuff
and the practice in Western Western
psychology civilization is the bath
exercise in delayed gratification and
the consequences of that are endless
unhappiness and new ropes the synthetic
substitution and so forth and so on for
reality it is good deliberate to know
that enough
but instead it's paralyzed with the
tenth of ephemerality went what it
should do is empower an enormous sense
of freedom and I think lifts ability to
accept the inevitable type thing and
coming to be a phenomena is what
psychedelic glutenin is really about
[Music]